if you move if you move the entire gauge
you you turn it and the needle turns
that doesn't mean the needle moved it
means that the whole gauge moved so
that's where we are Nvidia
[Music]
nvidia's RTX 4080 is a prime and
depressing example in a product
stagnation where it proves once again
that it is possible to launch a good
product which otherwise saps all
momentum and relegates it to
meh category it's a technical word and
sadly this is because as we've said for
a few GPU launches in the past several
of them and video in the last few years
actually for every one percent
performance uplift if you also spend one
percent more money that ruins the part
where it's cool it's no longer cool it
doesn't actually produce a meaningful
step for consumers where they feel like
the industry or the amount that they get
for their money is increasing CPUs are a
fantastic counter to what's happening
with the GPU market for NVIDIA at the
high end so if for any reason you doubt
well but why should we get more than one
percent more performance for one percent
more money look at the CPUs AMD and
Intel have beaten each other bloody for
four years now to finally get out of the
lockstep we were stuck in with
Haswell and Skylink and all the other
ones that were basically the same now
with CPUs you have prices that are
relatively fixed they're like plus or
minus 50 bucks each generation and we
still see improvements that are in the
double digits and that's because AMD and
Intel have beaten each other up over it
uh and and videos out here on the
fringes alone which is on one hand
impressive that they were able to get
ahead that much but on the other side
it's causing this problem and now amd's
trying to catch up with a 700 XTX and it
might be putting on video under some
pressure but not just yet so today we're
reviewing the twelve hundred dollar RTX
4080 16 gigabyte the one that's launched
not to be confused with the one that was
unlaunched and uh it launches tomorrow
the 16 gigabyte that is and you'll be
able to buy it then so at least you have
some time to watch this and find out
that it's probably too much money for
what you get let's get started before
that this video is brought to you by
thermal Grizzlies contact frame for
Intel 12th and 13th gen CPUs we
extensively test tested the contact
frame previously and found that it helps
better distribute pressure across the
surface of the IHS we saw this
contribute to a reduction in thermals
that could be of benefit to anyone who
needs thermal Headroom for overclocking
or especially thermal Headroom for small
form factor PCS the thermal Grizzly
contact frame is made in Germany with
Precision Machining and you can learn
more about it at the link in the
description below so here's a quick
recap of the basics the 4080 had two
flavors originally a 16 gigabyte and 12
gigabyte 12 gigabyte was unlaunched
Nvidia basically canceled it and we'll
be bringing it back later with a
different name they already made
everything their relabel and stuff
hopefully more than just putting a
sticker over it and that's going to come
out probably around CES in January
sometime most likely if it in fact
launches then it's going to have a new
name and it will have a new price we
don't know what the price is going to be
we know that the name is probably going
to be something like 4070 TI because
they already had a 4070 locked in when
they unlaunched the 40 80 12 gigabyte so
that's the history of that the 16
gigabyte still is a is very much a real
card it's here we tested it uh and to
get you up to speed on the specs here
the 4090 that's 1600 MSRP the 4080 is
1200 MSRP and then the 900.48-12
gigabyte again is a different story
we're not covering today the 4090 runs
24 gigabytes of gddr6x versus 16 on the
4080 we're reviewing today the 4090 has
16 384 Cuda cores and the 4080 has
9728. that is a massive Gap that is a
big enough Gap to drive a TI through so
you wouldn't be surprised if at some
point there's a 4080 TI or 4080 super or
something along those lines uh the 4090
has a TDP of 450 Watts the transients
actually were pretty good on that so we
did not see the massive transient spikes
that we were sort of expecting based on
power supply manufacturer rumors before
the launch but we already tested that
and talked about it in the 49-year view
the 40 the 80s a 320 watt TDP and then
as for AMD competition 7900 XTX 7800 XT
are the ones you need to know the names
of those will be 900 and a thousand
dollars uh and they launch around a
month from now December 13th so here's
the short version of what you're gonna
watch the uh gains for the well the 4080
achieves about 70 ish plus or minus five
percentage points of the performance of
a 40 90 and it does so while being 75 of
the price that's the short version for
rasterization now let's get into some of
the numbers and uh and then the
conclusion we'll revisit list some more
and talk about value for things like the
6000 series and the 30 series as they
linger in the market because they're
looking pretty good we'll look at
Thermals first test and import Royal
until steady state we noticed the RTX
4080 Fe held a GPU temperature Target of
60 degrees Celsius for its average
temperature The Hot Spot temperature ran
about 10 to 15 degrees higher at any
given point maxing out at 75 degrees
Celsius ambient for this was a fixed
21-22 C they're fantastic this is the
same chart except with fan speed added
the RTX 4080 Fe follows the same
behavior of the 4090 where the left and
the right fans spin at slightly
different pwm strengths and thus have a
different RPM this is likely to combat
undesirable noises the fan runs at about
40 percent and 37 consistently when at
steady state just as a quick reference
point here's how the auto settings on
the 4090 and the 4080 Fe cards compare
the 49 DFE runs about two to three DBA
higher which we'll show you in a second
so even with that higher RPM it's still
running warm and that's expected given
the larger core the 4080 runs as you see
here about eight degrees cooler than the
4090 when both are tested with the Fe
cooler and their default v-bios
temperature Target and fan curve it
helps to plot the frequency as well this
lets us know one that the card is
working properly and it also provides a
reference point for the future
especially if the drivers change the
speed Behavior here the card boosts to
about 27-75 megahertz and it then stays
there basically without any change for
the entire test there are occasional
flickers and frequency but nothing
relevant it's impressively flat here
that's something we saw on the 4090 Fe
also frequency is similar to the 4090 so
the biggest difference will be the GPU
core itself noise levels are the same as
the 49 DFE because they use identical
fans and coolers for reference on this
chart the 4080 Fe was defaulting to
around 38 to 39 DBA on the marker here
whereas the 4090 Fe was closer to 40 DBA
we'll start off with Final Fantasy 14 at
4K in this one the RTX 490 capped at 215
FPS average with both the new and the
old drivers but we're only showing one
of the results because they're the same
that means the RTX 4080s 152fps average
result has it 71 percent of the total 40
90 performance and with the 1200 versus
1600 MSRP it's at 75 percent of the
price it's not very compelling so this
looks like sort of a classic upsell
positioning on the 4090 versus the 4080
framed another way the 4090 outperforms
the 4080 by 41 while costing 33 more
money compared to Alternatives the 4080
works wonders to make early 3090 TI
buyers feel bad it outperforms it by 24
percent here the 6950 XT is the next
closest we hadn't actually checked
prices for this one in a while so a
quick glance at Newegg revealed a few
models at 800 some with rebates so they
run in the 700s at the cheapest that's
competitive pricing even against new
cards although there are clear downsides
and things like Ray tracing performance
that we'll look at later the 6950 XT is
114 FPS average allows the 408a 34 lead
at 50 percent more money the 30 90 is
around the same performance positioning
or close enough anyway and
generationally and by name only the 4080
leads the 3080 by 53 percent with a a
similar price increase on MSRP so that's
a one percent performance bump for every
one percent increase in dollars spent
which is what we call stagnation we have
a history of judging things this way
where when we see that one to one rise
over run for performance to price
increase that's what we Define as a
product which has not really moved the
needle now at the ultra high-end
Flagship category like say what would
typically be a Titan that's expected
Behavior
but we also judge those as very poor
value so it makes sense once you get
into these more gaming class cards even
at 1200 bucks we do expect to see more
than this and uh to be impressed we we
just we have to see better than a
one-to-one because otherwise if you
think about it you're not really gaining
anything new as a consumer it's great so
you can spend more money you get more
performance and it's unlocks that who
cares at 1440p the 4080 and the 4090 are
tied they're CPU bound so this test
isn't useful Beyond showing us where
that line is and of course CPUs also
limit GPU performance which we've now
learned once again so we'll move on in
total World Warhammer three at 4K
another dx11 title the 4090 LED at 125
FPS average with lows well spaced behind
it's pretty consistent here the 4080
achieves 70 percent of that performance
once again landing at 88 FPS average
with low space Also proportionally the
3090 TI gets close to the 4080 here and
as for the 3080 the 4080 weeds the last
gen namesake by 38 percent moving on to
amd's closest modern competitor until
the 7000 series comes out the 6950 XT
Flagship is led by 50 by the 4080. so
they're pretty far apart and we're
looking forward to seeing where the 7900
XTX lands once it ships because for now
the 6000 Series has clearly beaten out
thought pricing is favorable towards AMD
is 6950xt for now but clearly the
performance Gap is pretty large here at
1440p we still have scaling on the CPU
and we can see gaps in performance the
RTX 4090 leads the 4080 Fe by 34 with
the 4080 leading the 3080 by 46 percent
the 6950 XT lands between them and as
for the older Hardware owners of the
2070 would see a 200 increase here and
although we don't have a 2080 in this
chart we do have the 2080 TI the 4080
improves 98 over that and just as a
reminder when the 2080 TI came out we
said that the pricing was ridiculous
that was a 1200 card as well once again
the price is brutal on this where we're
seeing the same thing in the same one
percent performance for every one
percent dollar extra spent and even
adjusted for inflation uh assuming uh we
checked some random inflation calculator
we're not economists I don't know what
the inflation rate is in the U.S but uh
checking against the original launch
price and the launch date of the RTX
3080 versus today the random calculator
we found on the internet which is where
all things can be trusted suggested a 15
uh inflation so that would bring us to
about a 30 price increase for about a 40
something 44 45
performance increase which isn't one to
one but it's more like 1.5 percent more
performance for every one percent more
money spent and that's better than what
we saw in Titans where you'd get like
two percent performance for four hundred
dollars but in this instance uh although
it's better than that it's still just
not exciting the Nvidia needs someone to
kick them in the ass a little bit
because they've been alone too long in
the Market at the high end and Intel's
not anywhere close to that yet so
everybody's kind of looking at AMD
going
we we need some competition here to keep
this in check and keep it exciting for
everybody it would be good friend video
too because then if they have a stronger
launch in the future stronger value
proposition the reviews go from being
this is a good product we hate the price
to hopefully this is a good product
awesome price like we saw with the 3080
and the 1080 TI a mistake they'll never
make again 1080p should see some
tightening of the ranks both for
architectural reasons on Nvidia gpus
where these resolutions particularly
benefit AMD and for CPU reasons the RTX
4090 now has its lead cut down to 24 so
we're at the limits of what 1080p will
allow us to see for scaling and gpus
although this is still pretty damn good
given it's 1080p the 4080 isn't though
so we can still see how that does versus
everything else below it and that's
without a CPU impact here unlike the 40
90. the 4080 leads the 6950 XT by 34
here then the 3080 below that by 46
percent so you can see where the 6950 XT
or the 6900x just like we saw in
original testing they gained ground as
the resolution comes down following
these the 3070 and the 2080 TI are about
the same with the 4080 leading those by
around 95 or so and Shadow of the Tomb
Raider at 4K the RTX 480 ran at 148 FPS
average with lows at 130 FPS and 127. so
those are running tight together and the
frame times are really consistent on
these modern cars the RTX 4090 leads by
35 tier with a 4080 over the 3080 by 50
percent the 27 FPS average lead over the
3090 TI wouldn't be impressive except
the 39 dti's original price sort of
makes it impressive impressively bad
pricing for the 3090 TI at launch which
we already knew as for AMD it swings
close here but not close enough to take
second place the 6950xc allows the 4080
a lead of 29 but considering the 6950xc
launched at 1100 bucks and it's now 800
it still has price going for it at 1440p
we're Bound by the CPU in this game the
40 90 and the 4080 look the same when if
untethered they wouldn't be otherwise as
seen in the previous charts the 4080
leads the 6950 XT by 29 here so we can
see that there's still some scaling that
remains constant in this one the 4080
isn't fully locked up on the CPU like
the 490 is but it's getting close and
it's hitting it sometimes the lead over
the 3080 is 42 here Rainbow Six Siege is
up next first at 4K the RTX 4090 ran at
355 FPS average here with low spaced
strongly at 288 and 265. that has it 32
percent ahead of the 4080 similar to the
35 lead we saw in Tomb Raider and the 34
lead that we saw in total Warhammer
they're consistently spaced so far so
that at least renders the
decision-making process easier there's
not a lot of different numbers to think
about here in terms of performance gaps
the 4080 is 33 ahead of the 3080 here so
not as strong of a lead as we've seen
some of the other tests the 6950 XT
Trails the 3080 relatively closely with
a 2080 TI well below that at 150 FPS
average 1440p gives us comical frames as
Rainbow Six often does the 40 90 is 634
FPS average hits a sort of semantic
satiation except for FPS like it's so
many frames that the brain stops
understanding what we're even talking
about anymore the 634 FPS result leads
the 4080 considerably in absolute
numbers had a 120 FPS lead with a
percentage reduced down to 24 from the
previous 32. we're not at the CPU limit
yet that's around 677 FPS average with
our setup but we're approaching it and
if we inspect it this closely it might
be hitting every now and then the 4080
weeds the 3080 by 31 posting nearly the
same scaling we've seen in previous
tests even when Unbound it Trends down
with resolution the 4080 expands on the
30 series trend of boosting higher FPS
with higher resolution as for the 6950
XT the 4080 leads that by 23 percent
it's getting closer as the resolution
shrinks this is also a known Trend
Horizon zero Dawn is next we don't have
as many gpus tested in this one but we
have enough for a simple chart the 4090
ran at 165 of his average here leading
the 40 80 by 32 percent that's
consistent with the previous results and
in raw numbers it's about a 40 FPS Elite
not life changing for the amount of
money but then 125 FPS over 100 FPS
might not be either considering the
price Delta versus the remaining 3080s
in inventory and 6950 XT is on shelves
today the 6950 XT does well here out
doing the 3080 by 16 percent 1440p and
1080p were both CPU bound on the 4080 so
we'll skip those charts and not even
show them onto the ray tracing test
these have gotten incredibly complicated
to test GPS in general because not only
do we have to do rasterization where we
tested three resolutions now across all
the different games we don't even
publish all the games we test once we
start to see a pattern but you have that
plus Ray tracing and then just doing
Straight Ray tracings on up either
because we need dlsis or FSR or xcss any
of these super sampling Technologies to
accompany it because they also affect
the performance and they behave
differently for each vendor where
they're not all the same performance
uplift at a fixed like for like setting
so for this we test one game control
without any of the FSR dlss Technologies
at all and then the others we test with
those Technologies unless otherwise
noted so this kind of gives us a look at
both just the Raw Pure RT performance
versus
how it does when assisted with
technology we'll start with control for
this one we test it raw no supporting
Technologies enabled at all the 4080 ran
this at 52 FPS average allowing the 4090
Elite of 48 so that's actually a bigger
Gap than we saw before we typically were
in the 30 to 40 range for the 4090s lead
in rasterization it's disproportionately
strong here with rt compared to the
3080s 38 FPS average the 4080 gains
about 36 percent in average FPS the 6950
XT is 31 FPS average grants the 4080 a
65 lead comparatively that's massive
when considering the rasterization gaps
far closer range it's likely that Nvidia
will maintain an RT Advantage into the
Next Generation with rdna3 up next at
1440p the RTX 4090 leads the 4080 by 41
percent it's lost some lead compared to
1440p here that's not because of the CPU
Bond but probably just because some of
the demand shifts off of being as RT
heavy the 4080 maintains about a 30 FPS
lead over the 3080 here with another 10
FPS on top of that versus the 6950 XT at
1080p the Gap closes and we lose scaling
they're basically the same now only 10
FPS apart at the top end so we'll skip
this and move on cyberpunk is up next
and cyberpunk 2077 at 4K with Ray
tracing enabled we end up with a very
complicated Matrix of settings we're
testing with FSR and dlss in this
however for both settings we've tuned to
ensure a like for like base resolution
from which the image is rendered this
allows us to do a fair comparison
between them here's the chart the 4090
runs at 79 FPS average under these
settings with the 4080 at 58 FPS average
that's a 37 lead for the 40 90 so it's
comparable to our previous raster
differences the 4080s lead over the 3080
is a noteworthy 58 with a 6950 XT
allowing the 4080 an advantage of 100 at
1440p the 4090 leads the 4080 by 24 with
the 4080 maintaining a large lead over
the 3080 now at 65 percent 1080p was
locked to the CPU so we'll skip that one
shadow of the Tomb Raider is interesting
with Ray tracing because it only has RT
Shadows so it's more raster dependent
while still leveraging nrt feature the
4090 leads the 4080 by 37 percent back
in line with raster results mostly and
the 4080 leads the 3080 by 54 percent
6950xc is led by a similar amount F1
2022 is our last gaming test also with
Ray tracing here at 4K the 4090 ran at
84 FPS average a 50 improvement over the
RTX 4080 which itself was 45 ahead of
the 3080. scaling has now firmly
established a pattern so we can stop
with the game benchmarks because we're
not seeing much deviation time for the
last chart power testing for this we're
doing a simple full workload and for a
mark this is easy to Benchmark for gpus
because it's predictable and it pins
gpus at Max when power consumption
permitted through V bios it's also Fair
because it's the same on every card
retest the RTX 4080fe pulled 316 Watts
when stock measured out the pcie cables
and at the slot with the overclock
increasing that to 343 Watts the stock
numbers are effectively the same as the
3080 so at least in this regard nvidia's
efficiency or its performance per watt
has actually generationally improved
they've done better here the power is
also far reduced from the RTX 4090 which
ran at 496 Watts when stock in the same
test for reference the 6950 XT we
mentioned earlier was at 377 Watts
concluding then so to quickly recap some
of the numbers we ran through earlier we
were seeing again it's about 70 to 75 of
the performance of a 490 at 75 of the
price you can look at it another way
where the 4090 leads anywhere from 30 to
40 on average except when CPU
constrained where obviously just drops
depending on whatever that constraint is
in games like Final Fantasy we saw a
4080 lead over the 6950 XT at 4K of
about 31 four percent it'll have the
3080 by 53 percent and then Total War 4K
just as another example the 4080 led the
3080 by 38 percent you'll have the 69 50
XT by 50. Rainbow Six 4K I had the 4080
leading 33 over the 3080 40 90 leading
32 percent over the 4080 and then with
Ray tracing benchmarks we saw a far
larger Gap form and some tests that are
more RT Reliant whereas the games like
Tomb Raider where it's just one RT
feature and otherwise it's all
rasterization those basically resembled
the rasterization testing so as for
where that leaves us today well first of
all this is pretty disappointing
um 1200 it's like
it's just it feels like we're kind of
back to where we were
with launches
between 2020 and now between the third
the 3080 launch it was actually great I
mean price performance was there they
brought it down from the 20 series uh so
maybe some of that was maybe a little
bit of Stockholm syndrome there with the
20 Series where 28 TI came out 1200
bucks much like this is now although the
time's different obviously but the 3080
felt like a pretty solid launch and the
MSRP was the reason for that where it
was kind of like a call back to the 1080
TI 1080 TI is as a reminder different
time inflation differences too but 700
and regardless of inflation or economics
or any of that when it launched it was a
great thing for performance and value
and that maintained true for at least a
couple Generations the thing is still
holding on well so the 3080 felt like a
good call back to something that people
Associated positive feelings towards the
1080 TI and we lost that with the 490
clearly because it's more of a Titan
class card you never expect those to be
received well from a value perspective
the 4080 had a chance to sort of get
people back
interested in nvidia's new stuff from a
value proposition which is the most
important angle to to hold but it's just
it's not there and you know nvidia's CEO
can get up on stage and talk about how
low prices are or dropping prices are a
thing of the past as much as he wants at
the end of the day his own product is
killing his current products for Value
so if you don't need the newest thing if
it for some people you feel bad if you
buy something a generation old because
well you're buying a
2022 model and it's about to be 2023 by
the 2020 model and it's 2022.
realistically though it doesn't actually
matter if the product you're looking at
achieves what you want and right now the
cards are all so ridiculously high in
performance that if you take a step back
you look at those charts
just remember that if you're looking at
something where it's like
GN had to invest actual effort to create
a GPU bottleneck
probably for your purposes a 3080 versus
a 40 90 you're going to get better value
out of the older thing even though it's
technically a little older so as long as
you're okay with that and as long as
you're okay with throwing away a little
bit of future proof in because it's not
the newest absolute fin right now
uh you can put that money towards
something else a future proof elsewhere
instead or just save it for the next GPU
version so anyway all that to say right
now the 6950 XT is actually we hadn't
looked at the price until this review uh
it's in the 700s now 800-ish has sort of
a floor just quick glance at Newegg and
that's that's pretty interesting price
between the 3080 not too far off from
that
um and the 4080 is just not it for us
the value is not there and it's sad
because it's actually pretty good
product just in terms of performance
alone as is the 40 90. they've done well
with the engineering it's actually
impressive how much the 40 90 lifted up
from uh last generation and we expect
the 490 to be expensive there's got to
be some give here though somewhere for
the Enthusiast market and 1200 bucks uh
for this is is just not
we're stuck in one one-to-one rise over
run for Price performance and that is
how we Define stagnation
and if you think about it for more than
a second uh it should be pretty obvious
why because the needle has not moved if
you're moving everything with it if you
move if you move the entire gauge you
you turn it and the needle turns that
doesn't mean the needle moved it means
that the whole gauge moved so that's
where we are Nvidia uh hopefully AMD
kicks them a little bit in the ass to be
more competitive here on price and but
that's all we got for you on this one
thanks for watching as always
uh subscribe for more we'll have some
follow-ups I'm sure and you go to
store.gamersaccess.net tell us how
directly or patreon.com gamersnexis
um once again we're probably we'll be
looking at partner models I'm sure just
because
it is a good
product at a performance level but
um
we just we can't recommend it right now
today we'd say wait a little bit and see
what happens so we'll see you all next
time